so now that it is on all these great
platforms though what do you do to drive
traffic or just drive awareness really
because it sounds like you want people
to choose how they view it right what
are you doing to get that word out
because that's a route that's a part
that's like the marketers brain that's
not fun unless you love marketing which
some people absolutely thrive on some
some people are in front of camera
people and they're like I'm gonna sell
this thing I know how to do it let me
you know let me at this I'm not one of
those people I'm mostly a producer I'm
mostly the behind-the-scenes guy I'm the
guy who likes solves the technical
problems to make the director's vision
happen without anyone knowing you know
I'm the guy who who solves the tech
problems and and figuring out the camera
issues in like getting the actors on set
and figuring out budgets and like you
know making all that happen for someone
else's kind of dream so it's a very
interesting position to be in where it's
like I'm still the person championing
this project i'm still getting the word
out you know I've put in all the effort
so far so why not just do another couple
weeks of effort you know five years
what's another couple weeks I guess but
it is it is what you asked me how and
I'm asking you how I'm asking people to
tell me how how do you get a film out
where is where our people is it itunes
do really am I am I is that is that the
ultimate is that where people are do
people know the films on Amazon do
people know hulu it's sort of an
interesting world now where it's like
wow there's so many choices and it's so
crowded like I'd say you know of my
hundred filmmaker friends 95 of them
have films out that they're pushing that
are like projects that you know it's
like wow and I bet all them have friends
that also have projects it's it's an
amazing time so what have you seen work
and who do you not want to be you know
you either say I don't want to be that
guy that does all this it's like this
used car salesman that's always peddling
their film but then in some sense you
almost have to be because you can't just
be the humble filmmaker behind the
scenes and then no one sees your
beautiful work it's a really tough
balance it's a it's a fine line you know
how much do you say that your films
out hey my films up hey my thumbs up you
know at some point it's like you know
it's tough I feel like I'm about to like
go into another level of like instead of
like a Twitter or a facebook post that
like basically people only see if they
were on facebook at that one moment
because facebook now is just like whoa
there's so much going on and there's so
many pages sending with Twitter it's
like unless you're there in the 30
seconds on Twitter where you saw that
thing you're following two or three
hundred people or if you know 3,000
people how do you keep track of what's
going on you can it's just too much
going on and so you kind of have to find
people that like you know direct emails
this is happen and I'm finding I'm
finding a difficult reality where I'm
having to follow up I'm having to reach
out I'm having to follow up my follow-up
and sometimes it's worked out where I
followed up with a blog and then I
followed up my followed up and then
finally I hear back you know times are
busy we just went through South by
Southwest here in March and it's just
like you know the whole tech community
the whole film community kind of gets
sucked into austin and it's like don't
don't be trying to launch a film during
that time we did I mean sorry we put our
film out right at South by Southwest
which just happens to be our one year
anniversary of our film premiere so it
was tough I mean it's we're figuring it
out
you